the market in baghdad's tairan square
was packed with people
making the most of a sunny winter's day
we were there by the stands one man came
fell to the ground
started complaining my stomach is
hurting and he pressed the detonator in
his hand
it exploded immediately people were torn
to pieces
a lot of people died and were injured
the interior ministry says that as more
people flocked around the victims
the second bomb went off
it's the deadliest attack in central
baghdad since january 2018.
it also happened in tairan square
similar bombings were commonplace in the
capital in the early 2000s after the u.s
led invasion
and later as isil's influence grew
across the country
this part of the city became a fortress
surrounded by concrete blast walls and
checkpoints
but after the government declared isil
defeated in 2017
such attacks became rare and the extra
security was removed
the blasts come just a week after the
u.s confirmed it had cut its troop
levels in iraq
to just 2500 their lowest levels in
nearly two decades
but just this week iraq sent extra
soldiers to its border with syria
where isil still has a presence and to
tuskramatu
about 180 kilometers north of baghdad
isil has been trying to regroup and
recover but it's not been able to pull
off any major attacks
resorting mainly to guerrilla-style
warfare against the iraqi army
and paramilitaries many of whom are
backed by iran
just a few blocks from tairan is tahrir
square the centre of more than a year of
anti-government protests
demanding better security more
opportunities
and less foreign interference the
protesters also want elections which
have been postponed to october
analysts say several groups could
benefit from thursday's bombings
we've witnessed a continuous and a very
prominent rhetoric
from a lot of politicians and a lot of
militia leaders
that were protecting the government or
that were defending and supporting the
regime
against the civilian against the the
peaceful protests
for governmental reforms in iraq that
have continuously warned
iraqis in one way or another and
directly intimidated the protest
movement
that anti-governmental protests will
only lead
to escalations that would remind us to
the isis days
soon after thursday's attack much of the
evidence had been cleared away
and life was getting back to normal
iraqis are resilient
after so many years of conflict and
unrest
alexi o'brien al jazeera let's hear now
from our correspondent sumana fulton
who's been following events
in baghdad we're here at the site of the
incident in baghdad central tairan
square this is
the market where the bombs went off
earlier on thursday on the floor we can
see
burned pieces of clothing there is also
quite a bit of blood that is still
spilled which we're not
showing you because it may be too
graphic and people here are still
very much in shock they cannot believe
that
such incidents could once again return
to baghdad which has been
relatively stable and peaceful
since 2017 uh since
isil was officially defeated now many
believe
although there is no official claim of
responsibility yet is that
this attack bears the hallmarks of isil
what appears to have happened is that
the first suicide bomber feigned
sickness to attract
people towards him to help him and after
the first bomb
went off and people gathered to help the
wounded
that's when the second suicide bomber
hit
now you can see right now that many of
the shops here
are closed security forces have told
people to stay home to disperse in case
there would be further attacks but
normally this area would be extremely
busy it will be bustling
with people doing their shopping
at this time of the day and and many
people that
i've spoken to they are very fearful
that this incident could perhaps mark
the return of such suicide bombings to
baghdad the return of instability it's
only been a few
years since life has really returned to
normal
in the capital with people once again
going about their daily lives without
having to worry about
explosion we've seen concrete walls that
surrounded buildings to protect them
from such blasts come down again
revealing really the
city and uh and some of its
architectural heritage so there
there is quite a lot of shock there is
quite a lot of fear about what this
incident means for the broader stability
of the city but of course we have to
wait and see what the investigations
will reveal and we have to still
wait for the official claim of
responsibility
yes let's speak now too i've made arushi
who's the director of the house of iraqi
expertise foundation and joins us live
by skype from baghdad albert rushdie
welcome to the program
this is all tragically reminiscent of
days gone by isn't it
the last attack of this kind back in
june 2019
so given that are you surprised by this
well actually what's happened today is
one of the
massacres that baghdad didn't see for a
long time
starting from 2017 and
what's happened today show us is that we
don't
only have an economical political
problem but it looks like that we have a
security problem
that that this is what happened today is
actually a major security breach and
the the this possible
officials should should do something
about it because
if those two actually infiltrate
into a crowded market that means maybe
there are
others can be presented anywhere in
baghdad especially in the crowded areas
so you can imagine how much what's
happened today was very
uh very surprising for iraqis and it was
a sign a very bad sign
about the next day aren't these kind of
attacks they're
incredibly hard to stop
well it's supposed to be that we have a
major security plan
about securing baghdad and supposed to
be successful
in a way that like that before
uh the uh uh the security plan
was blocked uh was uh separated
into areas was there were there were so
many checkpoints in baghdad and all of
those things
actually vanished because it's supposed
to be that
we defeated isis eventually but the
problem now we are
reaching in a way that no we didn't
defeat daesh we need to make
more efforts on intelligent bases
in a way to know exactly what's
happening and to know exactly
what isis is actually planning the next
days
about reaching tobacco what do you make
of the timing of this
several things really day two of the
biden presidency just
five or six days since the the
announcement of the troop draw down and
uh the fact that there will be early
elections
to be held in iraq how does all this fit
into it
just i said in the beginning it's a very
bad message because
it show you that okay
the actual the government postponed the
elections until uh october
it's supposed to be on june but it show
you that
we need to change the system in a way or
another we need to
bring new uh uh officials uh
into the government bringing new ideas
about how to deal with the situation
in iraq especially especially which is a
very important issue that we have
an economical crisis which show you that
poverty can be raising up
which eventually it will help isis to
put more men
and women so you can imagine how much we
are in trouble in real
trouble and that's why i think uh
postponing the elections
uh well uh the the international issue
or let's say
the conflict between iran and the u.s
maybe has some sort of
some sort of a relationship but i think
the most important thing is that we're
going to focus
is supposed to be the iraqi government
focus on the local issues
uh focus on how to deal with the
security situation in baghdad
and how to have more and more uh
influential security plan to save people
especially in the capital that he
attacks me for a long time
i better rush it great to get your
expertise on this so do you appreciate
that thanks very much indeed